o ator diz pessoal de quem fala é o dark
e sejam muito bem vindos não mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que um bug mesmo
que eu ainda não tinha jogado olha só
como estava em frente eu já consegui
jogar dentro do próprio quarto que era
uma coisa que ainda não tenha
experimentado isso tá foco em nós a
bíblia que acompanhou vocês sabem que eu
fiz a série the big mac quando estava na
versão 10.1 ou qualquer coisa assim e
isso já é por si 13.4 na primeira ele
diz mary chan será mais difícil será que
eu vou tirar os fones porque está bem é
alto mesmo é e vamos lá então entrar
dentro do armário olha só para entrar
aqui só tem o tutorial tem o contínuo e
tem ninguém e tenho q soc nightmare the
night eu tenho que ter atenção ao rápido
senão isso sai do jogo entre o jazz esse
número supera algum cera do outro mundo
está em um lado da porta não contraiu o
agora já posso tirar foto edson ordem de
dentro do quarto
agora vamos ter que estar num movimento
já muito tempo que eu não jogo isto mas
eu acho que nesse jogo eu acho que sim
outra vez o calar obra pessoal pelo que
eu lembro pelo que eu jurei não é a nós
conseguimos passar esta noite sem estar
com nenhuma foto em pina e é isso que eu
vou tentar fazer agora eu só precisa de
usar bem me faz lhe diz ohtake
brinquedos 9 está aqui um super ao gol
preto dos kulina ou maligna do gene
abbott está eu não sei como dizer não
está super alto aumenta e também os
forma porque sim sinto um cinto com
companhia nesta quinta que não estou a
jogar sozinha esta primeira noite vai
fácil é isso que o governo está super
fácil mancha eu gostava de andar pela
casa e ver o que é que isto tem de novo
é que o lobby o início eu não tinha
visto ainda porque estes chá uma
transição bem típico eu acho que eles
vêm aqui é um ponto zero pois acho que
ganhei dois pontos qualquer coisa e esta
já equipa três pontos embora ouviram
além
segundo o governante a equipe mais
recente já melhorada tem novas texturas
e onde os jogos vão assumir o caso da
call com certeza não possa gastar pilhas
são duas e meia da não são dos 50 da
água está muito bem agora em princípio
eu já me pressiona porta chama
pressionando a inflação
antes de ficar na janela já não está na
janela aparece uma vez eu preciso 16
subtipos coisas dessas
cara eu tenho orgulho porque o fez
ela abriu a porta aí não só eu já ouvi
um barulho é que a foi o avião um fio
por cima que eu acho que foi isso pegou
uns porque né eu sei que está cheio quem
não vale a pena esconder se por dentro
do armário é preciso muita calma agora
eu já não aparece há muito tempo através
de espaço o game está com vergonha de
mim eh pá vamos voltar a dormir através
para botar fato é que não apareça na
urina por isso preciso função anda ok
avançam que quatro e 50 são 4 50 já tem
quatro passagens falta uma hora e meia a
um milhão dentro do armário sairiam
sexual viria como eu sabe contou um bom
fã de esquerda acho que vocês viram até
o tucupi youtube
buckman tabu e grande tabu é rio está
agora eu não diria manterá tudo preto
agora time que está em como as texturas
estranhas que não sabe não sai mesmo
documento está melhor agora e continua
dentro do armário eu acho que o meu de
golo estava vindo do inea samsung
correta agora falta 20 segundos após o
ciclo foi pelo teto
agora sai do armário como teto como
assim tá muito poderoso remédio está
daniel deus conseguimos passar a
primeira noite
lawson maior jogo não
deixa esse sistema é fácil veja só
pessoal dentro da casa agora sim o
equilíbrio dentro do hotel pouco
destruindo tudo não tem luz alguma coisa
assim mas não funciona
eu acho que aqui dentro vai rolar o som
mais uma vez vamos ter que ser rápido
antes que eu apareça aqui dentro da casa
outra vez né eu já não me lembro como é
que se abra portas só não abre é preciso
uma chávena eu acho que sim
magal deixaram león mex apanha a chave
aqui dentro a ser a casa de banho pois
levo da havan eu comecei aqui um outro
jogo era que supostamente começava a
atualização nep eu comecei dentro desta
casa de banho e eu acho que a chave
estava lá embaixo alguns por aí por vida
não era eu tinha primeira de apoiar a
flash lite eu acho que era isso vejam só
tabu é realista coisa ataquem já também
terá na cozinha exatamente toca aí agora
que acho que vai dar um susto nem acho
que vou morrer aqui umas coisas a não
ainda não eu não vou jogar mas não se
esqueçam magnética então é isso pessoal
vamos ficar porque com os filhos para
que vocês tenham gostado e essa foi a
atualização do blog eu não sei se você
já tem um bicho ou não e eu nem sei
sequer se tem alguma coisa que
classifica de muito boa dentro deste
burgman de como vocês o que aqui está em
única coisa nova que houve foi que foi o
passo inicial logo em poços podem estar
dentro do quarto e tal muito alto mesmo
mas que se tiver alguma coisa que valha
a pena mais pra frente de um e que você
joga mais à frente e sabem que o quarto
quero entrar em tudo aquilo 4 nightmare
do sul ao porto não só 10 quando como
flávio brito fica em maio do próximo ano